i remember when we first got legal in la
and i you know when they make things
legal but you're like but how legal
i mean legal for some people but not
legal for everybody you know and so i
remember when i when i would buy my weed
i'd put it on the passenger seat of the
car and so one day
i got pulled over right because i would
just buy the weight it's legal
and he pulls me over and i'm like whoo
we're gonna find out how legal it is
all right so i'm like okay
a guy comes up and he's got his
light and he shines into my face and he
sees the weed and he goes license
registration i go yes
sir and he goes do you know i pulled you
over i said no sir
and he said you rolled through that stop
sign back there
are you high son
and i said officer
never smoked weed before have you
because if i was high i wouldn't have
rolled through that stop sign
i would have stopped [ __ ] 40 feet
before it like
i might have got out of the car and
walked up to the [ __ ] stop sign
it's busy busy busy up here
i also have a real annoying habit when i
smoke weed in the car
um i sing very loudly
like i'm performing in front of 50 000
people do you all do that
yeah
now let me ask you the songs that i like
to sing the most are what i call guilty
pleasure songs which is a song you want
to sing but you won't sing until you
roll up your window so nobody else can
hear you singing the song do you all
have any guilty pleasure songs you want
to admit to
what what you got
slave by britney spears
what's that
what'd you say
yo i would love to see you just belting
out some adele dude
hey you want to give me a couple bars
real quick you want to give me a couple
bars
never mind i found someone like you
do you look in the mirror when you do it
too i got nothing then
don't forget me i think i remember you
saying
um
you know what my guilty i'll tell you
what my guilty pleasure song is and by
the way i learned guilty pleasure songs
from my dad my dad
he never knew the word sending the songs
either
which made it fun to listen to him
and his like his favorite guilty
pleasure song was total eclipse of the
heart like he'd be
he'd he'd be in the front seat [ __ ]
up those words just
he'd be like turn around every now and
then i get a little bit closer and
there's someone in the yard you're like
that's not the word
[Laughter]
that's not the word to any song ever in
the history of something
yo so my guilty pleasure song wrecking
ball
[Applause]
by who did you say by who
miley [ __ ]
cyrus let me there's more
there's one by eric churchill yeah i
will tell you something right now
if you tell me that you don't like
wrecking ball by miley cyrus i will tell
you you're a [ __ ] liar
is a jam so i was in i was high at the
drive through a taco bell surprise and
and wrecking ball came on and i just
started to sing like i was in front of
50 000 people i was like it came in like
a wrecking ball
i never hit your heart in love
all i wanted was to break your words and
all you ever did was
wreck
me
yeah you
you wrecked me oh i was [ __ ]
murdering you
and then i just heard
uh
[Laughter]
would you like to order something sir
because i was so high i forgot to roll
out the [ __ ] window
but i had been hired to drive through
for 20 minutes your goddamn right i
would like to order or something
i would like a grilled stuffed burrito
please absolutely anything for miley hey
[ __ ] you just get me the burrito
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]